u.s president donald trump has returned
to the white house after being
hospitalized for covid19 his physician
says he'll receive further care over the
coming days but
a number of white house staff have been
infected as well
we'll go live to our washington
correspondent after this report
it was a determined donald trump wearing
a mask
who emerged onto the steps of the
hospital
four days after he shocked the world by
announcing he
and first lady melania had tested
positive for kovid 19
trump was back after the short
helicopter flight to washington
the president crossed the white house
lawn
and strode up the staircase he made a
point of removing his mask
offering a salute to the departing air
crew
and there was encouragement for the
other seven
and a half million americans who've been
infected by the virus
don't let it dominate you
don't be afraid of it you're gonna beat
it we have the best
medical equipment we have the best
medicines all developed recently
and you're gonna beat it i went i didn't
feel so good
and two days ago i could have left two
days ago two days ago i felt great like
better than i have in a long time i said
just recently
better than 20 years ago don't let it
dominate don't let it take over your
lives
trump's democratic challenger joe biden
was
asked on television whether he agreed
the president had to bear some
responsibility for contracting the virus
anybody who contracts the virus by
essentially saying
mass don't matter social distancing
doesn't matter
i think is is responsible
those words will not be enough to deter
the president
in one of his many tweets on a day of
high drama
trump pledged to be back on the campaign
trail soon
let's get the latest now with stephen
simon's joining us from washington
good day to you uh simon um the
president may be back at the white house
sounding upbeat but
that does not end all the uncertainty
about his health does it stefan
no it doesn't and let's remind our
viewers this is a president on steroids
not figuratively literally steroids
and maybe that explains why he feels so
strong and so good after just two days
or almost three days in care of a top
team
of physicians and doctors who is
giving him any possible treatment the
best treatment possible
medic medicines etc which are
not at this point only early in the
disease available to
all the americans who are infected by
covet 19
who were not available which were not
available to all the americans who died
210 000 plus um so that's the difference
here and yes
it was a um a reminder
for everybody here in the u.s watching
this this was a bizarre
show this was the show man show with the
president
coming after a few days in walter reed's
medical center back to the white house
portraying himself as a strong man
basically as if he would have
beaten kovitz 19 again this is not a
prick in the finger or the sniffles this
is kovit 19. this kills people a lot of
people 210
000 plus i said that before the
president on the roosevelt
balcony taking off his mask and showing
to his base and to all american people
you see
i beat it is that true no it's not what
uh commentary did we get from this
well from um i'm just quoting you a
little bit
clown lunatic adjectives reckless
despicable
and even criminal now we will see how
this will all develop in the next few
days
uh stefan it's not just the president
the number of key aides have also been
infected
what does this mean for everyday
everyday business
at the center of power in the us at the
white house
i wish you could tell you that but i
don't know the white house is literally
a hotbed for coronavirus right now
and we the press are not uh
made to know if there is actually really
contact racing going on which should be
going on because
just today in a local time here in
america
uh the press secretary the white house
press secretary was tested positive uh
uh miss mccannon mcnaney uh two
other aides were tested positive so this
is not over for the white house this is
also not over for anybody who was in
contact with the
president in the last few days and
before he was
probably uh infected and then diagnosed
as positive
so this goes into the senate to the
congress house of representatives
there's hundreds of people in the white
house outside the white house part of
government to be
contact traced to be maybe tested and
then of course if
ill treated um this is a hot mess
a real hot mess right now devon thanks
so very much for that
from washington
u.s stocks rose to their highest level
in a month on monday
with investor confidence growing over
the possibility of a new fiscal stimulus
deal markets also appeared to be calmed
by
news that u.s president donald trump was
leaving hospital following treatment for
kovit 19.
positive economic data from the services
sector also helped
asian trading on tuesday also bounced
back
let's get more from our markets
correspondent chelsea delaney in
frankfort chelsea
markets across the globe very upbeat
about donald trump leaving the hospital
but experts in the u.s saying that the
president then
isn't out of the woods yet so all that
optimism could be premature
it certainly could uh there's still
clearly a lot of uncertainty
around donald trump's health and and how
long it will take for him to fully
recover
whether there will be long-term impacts
from
the virus but it does of course remove
some of this
some of these worst-case scenarios that
traders and investors had really been
fearing
it does remove the prospect of a lot of
chaos
in the white house um so that has helped
people
feel a little bit more comfortable but i
think also the the the progress that's
being made on stimulus talks in the us
is definitely helping to boost markets
as well republicans and democrats have
been negotiating for stimulus for for
several weeks now
but they we've heard from really both
sides of the aisle democrats like uh
speaker nancy pelosi
but also trump and some of his white
house officials as well
are really pushing forward and hoping to
get more than a trillion dollars in
stimulus to help offset some of these
continued effects of the virus on the
economy
chelsea on currency markets we see a
weaker us dollar
how does that fit into the picture
it might sound a little
counter-intuitive uh all of this
potentially good news for the us economy
somehow weakening the the currency but
the u.s dollar in addition to being the
the us currency it's also
one of the uh previous safe havens and
markets so
it does tend to rise whenever there's a
lot of uncertainty in the
um the the markets and now that we are
seeing some of that taken off
with trump recovering with the prospects
for stimulus looking better
with the outcome of the u.s election
looking a little more clear
that has helped people feel more more
safe and
so that's why we're seeing people sort
of go away from safe havens like the
dollar
chelsea delaney in frankfurt thank you